dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jonah a failure we
have reached a lot of milestones lately
for instance we now have over 1 million
views on the channel in the next few
days we're also hoping to hit 10,000
subscribers to put it in perspective in
2015 august the 20th we have had a 250
subscribers special episode where my
mind was pretty much blown that was
about nine months ago whoa for the
record here's an image that supposedly
contains ten thousand people just
imagine that they all have doctor'll
hats and you immediately have a mental
image of ten thousands of our fellow
scholars it's insanity and I must say
that I am completely blown away by your
loyal support thanks so much for
everyone for the many kind messages
comments and emails of which I read
quite a few in a second it just boggles
the mind to see that so many people are
interested in learning more about
awesome new research inventions and I
hope that it is as addictive to you as
it was for me when I first get to see
some of these results a huge thank you
also to our generous supporters on
patreon I find it really amazing that we
have quite a few fellow scholars out
there who love the series so much that
they are willing to financially help our
cause just think about it especially
given the fact that it's not easy to
make ends meet these days I know this
all too well being a full-time
researcher doing two minute papers and
having a baby is extremely taxing but I
love it I really do and I know there are
people who have it way worse and here we
have these fellow scholars who believe
in this cause and are willing to help
out thanks so much for each one of you I
am honored to have loyal supporters like
you we are more than halfway there
towards our first milestone on patreon
which means that our hardware and
software costs can be completely covered
with your help as you know we have
really cool perks for our patrons one of
these perks is that for instance our
professors can decide the order of the
next episodes and I was really surprised
to see that this episode 1 by a record
number of points looks like you fellow
scholars are really yearning
or some story time so let's bring it on
the focus of two minute papers has
always been what a work is about and why
it is important it has always been more
about intuition than specific details
that is the most important reason why
two minute papers exists but this sounds
a bit cryptic so let me explain myself
most materials on any scientific topic
on YouTube are about details when this
big deep learning rage started and it
was quite fresh I wanted to find out
what deep learning was I haven't found a
single video that was not at least 30 to
90 minutes long and all of them talked
about partial derivatives and the chain
rule but never explained what we are
exactly doing and why we are doing it it
took me four days to get a good grasp a
good high level intuition of what is
going on I would have loved to have a
resource that explains this for days
worth of research work in just two
minutes in a way that anyone can
understand anyone I haven't found
anything and this was just one example
of many Gandhi said be the change that
you wish to see in the world and this is
how two minute papers was born it has
never been about the details it has
always been about intuition I think this
particular comment is amazing and sums
it up really well these videos are
amazing just the right amount of
information to make you want to learn
more but enough to get a decent overview
of the subject this is exactly what two
minute papers is about get people
excited about research leave some room
for exploration and make sure the
resources to do so are given in the
video description box I wanted to
showcase this one comment but I started
looking through some more and I just
can't stop I hope you'll be as delighted
to hear them as I am thank you for
continuing to make these videos right
now I'm a student just starting to study
to become a date of scientists and your
videos inspire me and make me excited
about the future keep up the good work
Quinn I hope that these works inspire
you to be just as great as the
incredible researchers behind these
works if you look at the end of this
comment it says what's so great about
your con
is that you strike the perfect balance
of duration and information I've seen 30
minute videos that taught me less than
your short thing is thanks so much for
the comment and hmm nice name by the way
this has slowly but steadily become my
favorite YouTube channel hmm thank you
I'm very happy to have you around better
explained than my professor at the
University in one and a half hours
thanks please don't tell this to your
professor thank you I'm subscribed to
over a hundred channels but I look
forward to your videos the most by far
thank you for the great content Wow your
videos really inspire me and keep me
curious about science and technology I'm
super interested in machine learning
neural networks and artificial general
intelligence these breakthroughs in the
field you share with us from week to
week makes me feel that a new era is
coming and I want to be a part of it
thank you for inspiring young minds I
couldn't agree more there are indeed so
many works to be excited for I really
have a hard time containing my
excitement I don't know how you pump out
so many great videos so quickly truly
impressive in fact I'd like to do a
whole lot more and hopefully this will
be possible by doing it full time in the
future that would be really amazing
here's a message from someone who just
lazed through the entire series in one
go I hope one day we'll have so many
episodes that it will be a serious life
hazard to do so your channel is very
inspiring now I can think of anything
else than to work on science or
engineering I hope these works will
inspire you to greatness and please make
sure to write to me about all the
amazing stuff you created so I can have
a look I think this one was shown to me
in a forum topic about light transport
it seems to be written by a former
student of one of my courses in Vienna
in incognito hey there and thanks for
the kind words sometimes even the
authors of the people show up themselves
and fortunately so far not to tell me
how much I've butchered their work
some of my heroes and ID software are
also watching two minute papers and the
new doom game was also shipped on time
beta are ye is the CEO of Prezi and is
also one of my all-time heroes in my
humble opinion is about as good of a CEO
as any company could hope for there are
so many more kind messages that I have
in my mailbox thanks so much everyone
really appreciated I really feel like we
are just starting out and we're taking
the first few steps of a wonderful
journey let's keep celebrating science
together and remember research is not
only for experts it is for everyone
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time